now before we talk about another thing
very quickly uh daniel radcliffe time
traveler we've had this on the show
before right yes i don't know if you're
familiar with this uh dinoractop time
traveler this is the collection so far
right dan ragler
[Music]
i look like a lot of old women in the
past but very rarely men or boys about
two days ago like two days ago someone
found another one oh good uh this is uh
this is a young lady in 1922.
there she is
it is
i i don't these are all my past lives
and i just i a slightly depressed lady
in a lot of them yeah if you think
you've spotted danny rucker in a former
life do you get it but the viewers won't
let it go
daniel radcliffe
time
it traveler it is bizarre so now
so there's all the old ones we used to
have i think that was the first one we
ever showed there's a thing there's a
thing that happens when you come with
this stuff where the people
sort of uh dredged the internet and have
found photographs of of
people that look like me throughout time
and it turns out there's a lot of them
and a lot of them that's quite a good
one
[Music]
that one's that one's uncanny
that's well that's quite that actually
that is quite good i suppose
yes that's good that's pretty good
that's ridiculous
oh look there you are as a nun
[Applause]
bit of your life here there you go i
think you were in line
[Applause]
we've got some new ones like new ones
now weirdly we found one of you i think
you're married to robson jerome
[Laughter]
that's a walk though
this one is good this is again another
very very jolly bit of his life that is
really loving my fear
hello
thing you can do the dead i think yes
the dead i think was the thing i thought
everybody could do where i just sort of
make one of my eyes go like a bit lazy
and weird
yeah see some pieces some other people
can do it you're doing something
it's a it's effective i don't know what
yeah
i think i've got a slightly laser anyway
and so i just did that and then it just
it just makes me look very dead on
screen and as soon as and they put all
the other makeup on and stuff and when i
saw that it was like okay i don't have
to worry about playing dead i look
really really dead but they made a dead
daniel yes they did make a dead me i've
had dead meat made before but this was
the one that got put through the ringer
like a lot but paul dano wanted me on
his back most of the time he got very
strong i bet he did it around and dead
daniel much excitement because
dead daniel's here
yesterday
he's he's right here here is
dead daniel you're here the whole time
look at that inside
it's like it's weird because it's like
it's like he's it's like he's dead
it's like he's dead pop put it next to
me no no no you no
will he sit up not really
so yeah um
touch his head touch his
[Laughter]
he really is sort of falling apart at
this point but he's been sent down
rivers he got mauled by a bear like this
was all things we did to him during
filming and it's really good though look
at the look at the look at the the
eyebrows and stuff
yeah
it's just it's strangely horrible i
don't know i don't know what's happening
to it at the end of the press tour so if
anybody you know wants it
[Applause]
maybe not actually giving you enthusiasm
he will look worse
but yeah so much based on that reaction
there's no telling what type of uh
experience dead daniel could have yeah
so yeah it's
here or should i put him back i'm
leaving there for a bit okay cool you
tell me when you want him gone i mean
it's quite disconcerting because he is
sort of staring at me
[Laughter]
there you go
beautiful we know danny radcliffe you
have a reputation for being lovely to
fans you're very sweet you give your
time very freely to them but i read with
interest that you are starting to
toughen up now you're being a little
more discerning with your fans
um
what do you mean what what do you mean
well
wasn't there like you were being
generally nice but you were the friend
and she kind of went you know that yes
right well yeah
well because i
i think when when you like start acting
at a young age people expect you to be a
total dick all the time and that's the
kind of expectation that you sort of
always find yourself coming up against
and and so i think all my life i've like
been
really like worked hard to not be that
and to be like as far away as possible
but that has sort of sometimes meant
that like someone you can be really rude
to me kind of and i'll just be like yeah
fine
i feel like i won't really like notice
that you've been rude and uh sometimes
like people will come up and like 99 of
the time when people come up to you and
ask you for something on the street they
are really very nice and then just
occasionally like someone will come up
and i said somebody said can i get a
picture with you and i just you know i'm
just saying words not meaning anything
by it i just said yeah yeah of course if
you want to and she just went well i
wouldn't have asked if i didn't want to
i was like and of course i was like oh
no of course you wouldn't silly of me go
of
my girlfriend was with me and she was
like that girl was a dick to you you
don't need to like you need so she's
giving me like a little bit of sense of
uh like you can judge that not that i'm
like a dick back now or anything no i
just don't but you don't need to be that
but but apparently rupert grint's even
worse than you rupert i don't know the
details of this at all but rupa ended up
at somebody's house one night just from
like continuing to say yes to things
again i feel bad saying this because i
feel like someone's going to take
advantage of that and just like ask him
to you know he's going to be like the
new manchurian candidate or something
because sometimes people come up to you
and they don't mean to be rude but they
can be quite rude oh yeah i had um
i had at the premiere of was it
suffragette my wife just been in a film
and and i thought if anybody calls out
my name i'll go and cyanotographism as
it happened a few people sent didn't i
did that and so this woman was screaming
screaming screaming she was like james
james james thanks everybody dang my
thing and i came over and she went oh
thank you i'm a really big fan of some
of your work
i think yeah thank you i'll sign some of
your posters
okay that was kind of that was a weird
and people are trying to be nice to try
to be i think sometimes as well there's
a thing that people do where they like
and it is very particular particularly
like young men with me
want to do a thing where they want me to
know that they don't give a about
me like before they start asking for
something so they'll be like didn't
really like the harry potter movies but
can you sign this
like don't do that just say something
say a nice thing
it's so easy i had one i had one happen
really recently a fancy dress party
where um
and this is weird right uh do you know
that thing where uh some people make a
list
of
people famous people that they're
allowed to have sex with if they meet
them
oh the free pass the free pass right
yeah she called an allowance
and i was like what like pocket money
how are you going to spend me um
so
i met her on her fella and and then she
came up and said uh after she went so
you're my allowance
and i was like
excuse me and uh she went you you know
he's cool with it and you're my thing
and i was like uh
he's not cool with it by the way
by the way that's a whole other story
and uh and i was really sort of like
taking a backpack and i was like i'm
married and thank you very much it's
very very nice and then she said this
thing it was like it was meant as a
compliment and she was trying to get me
to do stuff but it was still really
backhanded and she went because you know
a lot of girls would be after somebody
like chan and tatum
[Laughter]
do you know what
you're no getting it
achievable goals
i heard you talking on a show where you
met
donald trump yes but not particularly
because you wanted to no i was i was
like i just i love real estate i have to
go meet him when i was younger
no i was like i was i was um like 11 or
12 and i was going it was when we were
doing press for the first potter movie
and they took us to new york and it was
the first time doing sort of the morning
shows in new york um and i was about to
go on the today show i've never been on
sort of american sort of morning tv
before i was quite nervous and uh donald
trump was also had also been on that day
and so that that's donald trump for
those of you who have blissfully
forgotten what he looked like
but he um then they sort of walked me
over to him because clearly they were
like you know somebody said hey you want
to meet the kid who plays harry potter
and he was like sure
conversation went but they uh they sort
of walked me over to him and he said oh
hi nice to meet you and i said nice to
meet you and i said he said how are you
and i said i'm really i'm quite nervous
i've never been on tv before i don't
really i don't know what i'm going to
talk about and he brilliantly just said
you just tell them you met mr trump
for me that's like that is the that is
the everest of self-confidence
like imagine if i just been to you like
when you go on that show just talk about
me
talking about your stuff just looking
like two americans and we're both just
like like sad yeah
you're already sad
yeah i know you're all laughing and also
the problem
but also this is kind of the problem
because you do end up talking about him
yeah and you know we should be talking
about the other people because i know
you're i mean the beauty of the whole
thing is you have to because he just
doesn't talk about himself you feel like
you have yeah
presumably you are familiar with uh
miriam's potty mouth because uh or are
you because you were in high body but
did you actually work together yeah yeah
yeah yeah
but i don't remember i've been told
there was a swear jar involved on set
but i i can't remember that i don't
remember you swearing a lot in front of
me i was probably careful when it was
you but when you know with the other
kids i didn't bother
he's the lead
i was just talking backstage if that's
what you call that funny little
girl
and apparently it's 20 years since
harry potter came out since we started
filming the first one and your balls
have dropped since then i can tell you
that
it's uh
it's a relief to us
i hope so
because they're just we kids there we
get it yes
yeah but but it's interesting because
professor sprouse which you know you
were in the second film and the last
film yeah i should have been in all of
them yes and that was a brave oversight
i'm holding you
but anyway it was wonderful to be in the
two that i was in and i'm very proud of
it but you do get recognized as
professor sprout i do i i mean i think
i've changed since then but people do
recognize me and
funnily enough in lithuania
i was i was lithuanian
are you have you come just to see
professor sprouse i don't think so
are the films called professor sprouse
no but i was mobbed in lithuania maybe
because i was jewish i don't know i'm
the only one there
[Laughter]
stop cheering now
but i just think that's incredible like
you're being mobbed in lithuania and
you're professor sprouse imagine being
this guy i know what what was it like i
mean
it's weird and funny and i think i the
best way to see it always was like weird
and funny because it will it you know
and it ebbs and flows and sometimes it's
in your life a lot and sometimes it's
not in terms of getting recognized and
there's been lots of very odd moments i
was chased out of a science museum in
spain um and i was just like but it was
sort of fine because everything was in
spanish there and i couldn't understand
anything inside so it was time to leave
anyway yes
and then uh so yeah you got but someone
thought you were something else in new
york recently oh yeah
you know what actually this didn't this
did not come up in in with it yeah so
i did recently so me and my girlfriend
fostered a dog uh and it's we sort of
got our friends to adopt it this is not
necessary for the story there's a dog
with me um
i i i was on the street with this dog
and my girlfriend was in the shop and so
i was it was very cold
i've got my hoodie and my fleece uh my
fleece hoodie and then a big coat over
that and the dog was really cold so i
was like i'll just kneel by you and like
stroke you and like try and keep you
warm and then uh and then i saw this guy
like look up at me like 10 yards away
and smile and i was like yeah and just
carried on and then he walked past me
and he came back uh like you got about
five steps past me and then just
reappeared with a five dollar bill over
my shoulder and just went get yourself a
coffee mate
i i really like my girlfriend came out
and i was like i don't think i'm great
i'm like i'm wearing nice clothes i
thought like
like i don't know yeah so i was i was
very i was like
that was a wake-up call apparently i
have to maybe you know don't worry
on a string
i do maintain because the person that
owns the dog has also been mistaken for
a homeless person with this dog i think
the dog just looks very cold and sweet
and vulnerable
no i know
[Music]
you